Speaker 1: Let's go next to Moni
from the United Kingdom. Moni,
welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: I actually just got back
from work. I love the show. I just
want to say keep up the good work.
Speaker 1: Well, welcome. Thank you.
Speaker 3: So I wanted to bring something up
that has been playing on my mind for a bit now,
and I never really saw anyone bring it up. And
it's when Barton did the State of the Union
address fairly recently. Yes. No one seemed
to point out that when Biden brought up the
whole idea of funding the Border Patrol
officers actually getting the money and
equipment that they deserve and they need
it on the CNBC news station actually cut
to Ted Cruz and his reaction. He
was sitting there shaking his head
and complaining. And I just don't get why.
Speaker 1: Oh, it's. I mean, I don't know
how familiar you are with in general, how
it's a complete partizan show, but yeah,
it's mostly that. I mean, it's, you know, that
that's what people like Ted Cruz have to do.
They have to complain, They have to shake
their their head. They have to act disgusted
even about, like, uncontroversial things.
Speaker 3: Yeah. I mean, it's just such a
shame because, I mean, clearly that's he
always says that the border needs to get
more funding and more equipment and stuff like
that. And and then as soon as it's proposed,
he sits there and shakes his head like. But
you know. Yeah. Like who he is. But it's it's.
Speaker 1: It's pathetic. It's what it's what his
voters expect him to do. And he's not a serious
person. That's the reality.
Speaker 3: Not for.
Speaker 1: Listen, can I ask you a question? I'm
curious if you have some insights. Yeah, I'm soon
going to be making my triumphant return to
the United Kingdom, and I'm going to have the
opportunity to spend a little bit of time on the
south coast of England, you know, where Brighton
and Bournemouth. You know the area?
Speaker 3: Yes. Yeah.
Speaker 1: If I had the opportunity to choose
any place to spend a few days in that area,
is there a particular spot you would
recommend, like is Brighton better
than Bournemouth or what? Where would you go?
Speaker 3: I haven't really been to Bournemouth
in my life. I'm kind of almost between
Brighton and London. Okay, It's where I live,
but I go down to Worthing and Brighton quite
often. Brighton's really nice is what a lot of
us like to call the LGBT capital of Brighton
for the most part of the south of Britain.
Speaker 1: Oh really? Well, those spots
usually have some of the better food scenes.
Is that the case in Brighton as well?
Speaker 3: Brighton does have a lot
of good food options. Oh, interesting. Yes.
Speaker 1: And it's right on the water, correct?
Speaker 3: Yeah, it's right by
the beach front, depending on
where you stay in Brighton, of course.
Speaker 1: Maybe Brighton is the place
to check out. That's interesting.
Speaker 3: Yeah. It's always the
go to beach area. I think. I'm not going to
speak for all people from the UK, but you.
Speaker 1: I would. I know you would never do
that. You would never. All right, good. I'm
going to look into that. I appreciate the advice.
Speaker 3: But no, I love I've been looking a lot
into U.S. politics recently and you've been doing
some good work on this. So thank you for all that.
Speaker 1: I appreciate that. Thank you so much.
Speaker 3: Yeah, thank you. Have a good day.
Speaker 1: All right. Money from the UK, folks.
Let's end it there, because we couldn't possibly
end on a higher note. We will take calls
again and I hope to hear from you next time.